it's been 20 years this week since the
Bali bombings in 2002 two bombs ripped
through a pair of packed bars in the
district of kuta it was Indonesia's
worst terror attack
[Music]
it's huge it's scary
people are burnt everywhere
202 people were killed in the Bali
bombings mostly foreign tourists among
them 88 Australians there was also a
huge amount of damage throughout the
densely populated area where the attacks
happened many people were also injured
some severely with extensive burns the
attacks killed people from 21 countries
well the attacks were widely blamed on
Jamar islamia a Southeast Asian militant
group with ties to Al-Qaeda now that led
to huge counter-terrorism and
de-radicalization efforts from Indonesia
though the number of Terror attacks
there has fallen there are questions
over whether these efforts were too
aggressive and overreaching our team
followed one person who joined
de-radicalization program and came out
the other side
living a Farmer's Life something hendro
Fernando could never have imagined
possible the 38 year old is Raising some
4 000 quails at this Farm in bakassi
West Java it's a complete turnaround
from his previous life like all workers
at this Farm Fernando used to be part of
a terrorist Network an Isis fighter who
was involved in several Terror attacks
in Indonesia he was arrested in 2016 and
released four years later
I used to be like whoa what's the latest
weapon how much is that now I run this
Quail Farm
Fernando is one of some 300 convicted
terrorists in Indonesia who over the
last few years have decided to join a
state-sponsored the radicalization
program initially the father of two
refused to cooperate
then I got to know some fellow convicts
in jail who had cooperated with the
Indonesian government and had renounced
violent extremism that got me curious a
few weeks later I asked for access to
the library and got it I started to read
at the change and eventually mustered up
the courage to pledge my allegiance to
Indonesia in 2018. the the
radicalization program was established
after the deadliest terrorist attack in
Indonesia's history the Bali bombing in
2002 the attack killed 202 people
including 88 Australians one of the
terrorists convicted for that attack
bomb maker Umar Patek also participated
in the radicalization program
he is about to be released on parole
seven years early like other inmates the
former terrorist was rewarded with a
reduced sentence after joining the
program
s
radicalization program The Challenge is
that it always needs to be tailor-made
take for instance Umar Patek you need to
analyze his behavior in prison
understand his interests learn what
skills he has all that needs to be
assessed so the Der radicalization
program works for him and for other
former convicts
experts agree that simply incarcerating
Indonesia's some 500 convicted
terrorists for life is not a long-term
solution but as Indonesia's prisons
filled up with new terrorist detainees
the state with socialization program
will soon need additional funding
Henry Fernando's neighbor at the quail
Farm is certainly convinced that the
floor jack is worth
we should embrace them if we don't they
could go back to where they used to be
we don't need to be harsh on them we are
all one people after all
initially was nervous about his
neighbors now he is a frequent customer
and often comes to the farm to buy quill
eggs he like the state believes the
former convicts should be given as
second chance
champion
let's go to Bali now and speak with DW's
Asia Pacific bureau chief gig OG matters
hi there Georg this is a really
significant anniversary of the Bali
bombings many people locals and
foreigners have been battling trauma for
many years now two decades how are
people there feeling this week
I would say essentially you have two
groups of people you have of course
those people who are not just physically
but also mentally scarred for life and
I've talked to one person who said she
will attend but she will she has mixed
feelings for it because even the sense
of smoke sometimes triggers panic
attacks so she isn't sure how uh coming
back to the very site where the bombing
happened for a memorial ceremony uh will
affect her and then on the other hand
you have people who feel it has quite a
healing feature that it is good for them
to confront themselves and to also see
that life goes on and that is something
that many Australians the the nation
that has been hardest hit with 88
casualties in this terrible bombing many
Australians have said let's return to
Bali for this date uh in also to support
the country that has suffered
tremendously in the pandemic with
tourism only recently bouncing back a
little bit
um Guild there are commemorations of The
Barley bombing bombings happening of
course in Bali Australia too uh what
exactly is planned
well you have in Legion Street uh the
very place where the body bombing
happened a memorial a peace Memorial and
there will be a peace prayer uh tomorrow
there will also be a small ceremony at
the Australian consulate here in Bali in
the morning and then of course across
Australia you have a number of Memorial
sites where there will be ceremonies
now Gail these bombings in 2002 really
through the problem of terrorism in in
Indonesia into the spotlight could you
talk to us a little bit more about the
efforts that Indonesia has made on
counterterrorism since then
quite a number of things here in
Indonesia one amongst them is aggressive
police work so Indonesians have been
quite Vigilant about for instance
Indonesian citizens returning from Syria
who went directly to jail ever since the
body bombing more than a 1 300 people
were arrested on terrorism charges so a
quite effective police work then we saw
in the report of course the
de-radicalization program there is
lately some criticism regarding the fact
that Indonesia has broadened the aspect
of of terrorist organizations to
non-violent organizations and some have
said that makes the target so wide that
there could be a political element to it
as well so some people say that that
does not exactly help the mission to to
stop terrorism in Bali and across
Indonesia okay now one of the main
masterminds of the Bali bombings is
someone known as Uma Patek he's due to
be paroled soon how are people taking
that
well you have of course those amongst
them the Indonesian government itself
who was very proud on its deer
radicalization program and and say uh
there is no use in uh locking people up
and throwing away the key
um you have to de-radicalize people and
Uma Patek is one of those uh Prime
examples that is celebrated a person
that is celebrated as a success he
deeply regrets what he has done and he
wants uh to convict others uh other
potential terrorists and also people who
are in jail with uh terrorism suspect
numbers rising in Indonesia that this is
the wrong path and they have to return
to a peaceful peaceful path and then of
course you have those victims who have
lost their loved ones for life and who
argue you know releasing someone like
him especially of course around a
special date like this one uh um only
hurts and it's also unfair seeing that
they have lost someone for life and and
he's getting out early
that was DW's Asia Pacific bureau chief
Georg Mata speaking to us on the 20th
anniversary of the Bali bombings in 2002
Georg thanks very much